Narrator: Whenever
the president flies
on an Air Force plane,
its call sign is
Air Force One.
But what if a president flies
on a commercial plane?
What would air traffic control
call the plane
flying the most important
passenger in the country?
- Well, President Richard Nixon
tried to do that.
- We face the possibility
of temporary fuel shortages
and some increases
in fuel prices in America.
narrator: In the midst
of the 1973 energy crisis,
with the cost of fuel spiking,
Richard Nixon became
the first and only president
ever to fly on
a commercial flight.
- One of the things
Nixon was doing
was trying to show that he
wasn't wasting gasoline,
that he wasn't burning gas
for his vacation.
"I'm not one of these fat cats
spending money
"when oil is so expensive
and I'm riding on
the taxpayers' dime."
[whimsical music]
narrator:
The day after Christmas,
the Nixon family, his staff,
and a dozen Secret Service
agents
boarded United Airlines
Flight 55,
a DC-10 from Washington
to Los Angeles.
♪ ♪
- The plane was then known
as "Executive One."
That was its call sign
in air traffic control.
♪ ♪
narrator: According to press
reports at the time,
flying "Executive One" saved
at least 60,000 gallons
of jet fuel.
- If the energy crisis
continues,
the President may find this
is the only way to fly.
Ed Schumacher, ABC News
in Los Angeles.
- What most of the American
public didn't realize was
that Air Force One flew
to California
empty anyway
to pick up President Nixon
in California and bring him
back to Washington.
And so the trip was entirely
a photo op.
[dramatic tone]